NEWSPAPER.
AT LEAST FIVE DEAD AND SEVERAL
INJURED.
SHOT AND KILLED AND SEVERAL MORE
INJURED AT AN NEWSPAPER IN AN
SOME OF IT CONFUSING.
WE ALSO EXPECT AN UPDATE FROM
POLICE AND THE NEXT FEW MINUTES
AND WE WILL TAKE YOU THERE LIVE
WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THERE WAS AN IDEOLOGICAL
THAT MEMBERS OF THE PROGRESSIVE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS SEEM
EMBARRASSED BY IT.
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
OPPOSE THE IDEA AS DID MANY
OTHERS.
THEN EVERYTHING CHANGED.
TWO DAYS AGO A SELF-DESCRIBED
SOCIALIST CALLED ALEXANDRIA
SHE RAN ON ABOLISHING I.C.E.
SUDDENLY IN DAYS, ABOLISHING
I.C.E. IS SOMETHING MANY
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY ARE FOUR.
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE
APPROACHING SO IT'S TIME FOR THE
REST OF US TO TAKE THIS IDEA
SERIOUSLY.
WHAT EXACTLY WOULD HAPPEN IF THE
LEFT KILLED I.C.E.?
HERE ARE SOME OF THE FACTS ABOUT
I.C.E. IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL
LAST YEAR THEY ARRESTED 32,958
IMMIGRANTS WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS.
ALMOST 5,000 OF THOSE WERE
MEMBERS OF VIOLENT GANGS.
WITHOUT I.C.E., ALL THOSE
CRIMINALS WOULD STILL BE AT
LARGE WITHIN OUR BORDERS.
LAST YEAR I.C.E. ALSO SEIZED
2,370 POUNDS OF FAT KNOWN, THE
NARCOTIC THAT IS DRIVING THE
SINGLE DEADLIEST DRUG CRISIS IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S ENOUGH FENTANYL TO KILL
WITHOUT I.C.E. THAT WOULD STILL
BE IN CIRCULATION.
THEY ARE ALSO THE BODY
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEPORTING ANYONE
ILLEGALLY INSIDE THE
WITH IT.
WITHOUT I.C.E., CRIMINAL ALIENS
COULD SEE IN THIS COUNTRY WITH
IMPUNITY INCLUDING GANG MEMBERS,
CHILD MOLESTERS, DRUG SMUGGLERS
AND CONVICTED MURDERERS.
THEY COULD NOT BE DEPORTED.
COMPANIES COULD BRING IN AN
FOR AMERICAN WORKERS EVEN MORE
THAN IT ALREADY HAS.
THAT WOULD BE A DISASTER, BUT
THAT'S THE POINT.
THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST I.C.E. IS A
CAMPAIGN FOR HONEST COMIC OPEN
BORDERS AND SOME ARE HONEST
ENOUGH TO ADMIT THAT.
ACTIVISTS HAVE CHANTED THIS, NO
BORDERS, DONATIONS, STOP THE
DEPORTATIONS.
NO BORDERS, NO NATIONS.
ONE LEADS TO THE OTHERS, ALWAYS.
WITHOUT BORDERS, NATIONS ARE IN
TROUBLE.
IF THEY PASSED THE LAW TOMORROW,
WOULD YOUR HOUSE STILL BE YOUR